am I supposed to stick my dick in there
or what I don't today we are guessing
women's item tampons maxi pads and that
has a wife yeah I have met women yeah
we're gonna win we are going to use our
deep deep knowledge of lady stuff I'm
talking about how to deepen it bring on
bring on the ladies product what the
heck it's a Vader helmet just like
cupcake tray because that's that's
sexist this is a hair dryer right how am
i life this like can men figure out how
to open their container so here guy
[Music]
oh right we are one for one I got two
guesses there's either for your hair or
vaginal steamer this is a fishhook oh
yeah thick wrapping up and then you then
you climb up yeah there you go Robin
holy applesauce
oh yeah you go you you're if your IUD
gets stuck it's like throwing the
grappling hook in yeah Oh si UD this is
an IV it is an IUD holy IUD
yeah the thing that goes right here here
either goes here or goes up in you but I
know it stops the babies right yeah two
for two
having my shoulder muscles this is how
my grandma works out this is to take the
oil off if we're getting four hand Emma
right oh that's what I thought
yeah I think it is they eat out with
this yeah it's for when you go down on
someone but don't want to get an STD
yeah I assure you we should use this
what have you had no clear to use it
like you like handles and you just like
whip it out you ready
Wow this is weird to lick it takes like
float it tastes like what a condom
tastes like it tastes bang like licking
this isn't funny how the try guys to
lick the other moment on the face like
this and they'll do it I feel like I
said no witness that I feel like I'm
being tricked with this one oh goodness
what it's big for her the gel grip does
make my ovaries feel good so we
obviously want I thought that I knew
things but I guess I don't I was a solid
B average bone bone bone like this one
like watching my mom women are heroes
doctor here
I don't think I can get a [ __ ] with a
dental I don't know if the jokes are
crossing a line or not we'll have to
we'll have to check it out later